تقع بين غابة استوائية في
جزيرة بالي الإندونيسية ، القرية الخضراء
لا تقف أمام المناظر الطبيعية التي
تحيط بها
مستوحاة من الطبيعة ، هذه
الهياكل الشاهقة غريب الأطوار مصنوعة
بالكامل تقريبًا من الخيزران ،
أود أن أقول إن الجانب الأكثر مكافأة
للعمل مع الخيزران هو الفرصة
لتعلم كيفية
الرقص مع شيء
ما للعمل مع مادة لا يمكنك
التحكم فيها بشكل كامل ،
فنحن في العقود الأولى من أخذ
الخيزران على محمل الجد
كمواد بناء
، ولذا فهو يظهر لنا كثيرًا
أن التطور هو من بنات أفكار
elora  هاردي المؤسس والمدير الإبداعي
لـ ibuku ، استوديو تصميم
يستخدم الخيزران والمواد الطبيعية الأخرى
لإنشاء منازل مستدامة ،
يعتبر الخيزران مادة رائعة
لأنها تنمو في معظم القارات في العالم ،
فهي تنمو بشكل رائع هنا في آسيا
وعبر المناطق الاستوائية خاصةً أنها تذهب
من لقطة صغيرة إلى عمود ناضج كامل في
غضون ثلاث سنوات فقط ،
وهذا أمر غير عادي
للاستدامة
للتجديد من
أجل الوفرة ولإتاحة الفرصة لتكون
قادرًا
على العمل والبناء
بشيء لا تقلق بشأن عدم استخدام
الكثير منه ، فأنت لا تشعر
بالقيود بشأن
إظهار الطموح الذي يصنعه هاردي
بمثابة نصب تذكاري لإمكانيات
الخيزران وقدرته على إحداث ثورة في
صناعة البناء
هنا ما كان يُعتبر ذات يوم
مادة متواضعة يرتفع إلى آفاق جديدة.
كمواد مفيدة طويلة الأمد
لأنها لم تكن متينة ،
والآن فقط لدينا حلول معالجة طبيعية
آمنة يمكننا
التفكير في بناء مثل المباني متعددة الطوابق
أو المنازل التي يجب أن تستمر
لعقود أو حتى
قرون ، أعتقد أننا كمصممين
تتحمل مسؤولية إعادة اختراع كل شيء
في العقود القادمة ، فسترى
ناطحات السحاب وحتى المدن بأكملها التي
يمكن بناؤها
من الخيزران  لن يبدو y مثل
أي شيء رأيته مصنوعًا من الخيزران من
قبل
لأن ما فعلناه هنا هو مجرد
جزء صغير من الاحتمالية
التي نحتاجها للتفكير في الشكل الذي نريد
أن يبدو عليه المستقبل
وتصميمه بدلاً من محاولة ذلك
قرص الماضي